hey how you doing hey is far
congratulate your medal in your heart or
or you didn't see or chose to skip the
first one in that you just work up to
the me in the middle of the conversation
I just want to concentrate to our two
yeah because everyone knows our two is
when movie discussions get really good
yeah by our two we will have definitely
talked about the movie to some extent
we're midway through the second act you
know okay we go break into the real meat
of the story yeah we got getting too
into the the journey to the inmost cave
sequence for all you guys that are up on
your [ __ ] Christopher Vogler Joseph
Campbell last year yeah the hero with
too many faces super much faces soups
face is like one of those Buddhist
deities that have to face on the sides
of the head in the front and make every
expression he can feel all things he can
suppress yourself and don't hurt anyone
he this boot is dead he could have all
for the Cardinal emotions North anger
Kanye and disappointments got a Twitter
account the other day it was a Kim
Kirika Kardashian which is just like all
these weird like according to the
description it's mashups of Kierkegaard
its philosophy and Kim Kardashian tweets
so it's all like this philosophical
stuff that ends with like but you should
really take care of your skin though
okay okay like that always good I feel
like that's gonna really break the
internet if anything oh yeah not like
barring like a massive power surge
somewhere that just chain reactions
everywhere yeah it's also a thing I got
a script about that kind of roundabout
way so go ahead and enjoy sedition more
about this [ __ ] robot movie and
remember stay dank yeah yeah I'm I'm
sorry I'd here in the Norwegian
mountains I got [ __ ] some time yeah
and I found that very I find them you
know I've had a very cool that the movie
does go there and it does handle it not
jokingly it doesn't vary
intelligently yeah I feel like Alex
Collins got that got that balance down
because you know it's like certain
certain sci-fi scripts can be more you
know more scientific more idea heavy and
and you know the people or colder
whereas this one it's like the people
feel really human do it's like this guy
clearly understands a bit of psychology
a bit of just people do and also the
ideas are big and the ideas are also you
know scientific and that's also
something that's really cool about the
movie in that um I'm sorry to backtrack
to the other tangent but sleights all
right when you steer we're man yeah not
that far bad hit by this back we gotta
The Truman Show ya know when um no one's
like caleb is watching Ava on the CCTV
monitors and you see like that male gaze
e stuff going on it's like we were like
this is the moment where is like Caleb
acts are very uncomfortable when first
of all he's super uncomfortable when Ava
starts flirting with him then he acts
super uncomfortable when when Nathan
tells him that ava is capable of [ __ ]
yeah and then and then it's like all
that stuff is start to really worm its
way into his brain when he's watching
her on like get dressed or undressed on
the monitor and suddenly it's like
suddenly this robotic body that looks
like the least sexual thing in the in
the world somehow it's like the camera
has turned it sexualized yeah it's like
it's it's mesh and and frames and and
metal plates and wires and a few glowing
LEDs but suddenly it's like suddenly a
dessert 0 the object it's the object is
personified is objectified yeah if
Justin like one very rapid little
stepstool in rapid succession this an
object becomes becomes human becomes an
object again oh yeah in the new context
you watch him just discover the idea
what about Trek to me and then like a
couple of seats leather it's like no
yeah that's a real thing like she's
actually feeling that then it's like oh
yeah yeah I can feel it back that
because
might be yeah and what's interesting and
then turns that back yeah well no it
turns out not look for a different
reason yeah for an entirely different
much more yeah that's something that I
appreciate worse and that's another
really awesome thing about this movie
it's like at the core of it when it
handles AI is like what makes it what
makes Ava so problematic and so scary is
not what makes her different from people
is what makes her similar to people the
fact that she has a strong desire and
will you know circumvent ethical or you
know empathetic action to fulfill that
very strong desire yeah it's like she
needs to be free of Apollo yeah and not
[ __ ] I feel like I haven't set the
time down to work it out but you know
Bob shipment there's another 42 book was
written like oh I haven't worked out the
I haven't worked at the math out
entirely for Bob Chapman's board I think
you know same 42 from Bob Shipman eyes a
project I i read a hitchhiker's guide oh
recently yeah oh that's right as a whole
supercomputer yeah an artificial I've
read hitchhiker's guide I've read all
five books oh [ __ ] yeah I gotta read the
next four books you don't read you don't
need to read the very last one is there
the one that the other author wrote no
you don't need to rebuild a sex book
yeah there's a six book and the the six
book has is written to kind of undue bad
stuff and even the fifth book oh yeah oh
god what happened I what happened while
I was away um douglas adams had a really
bad year when he wrote this book is it
just bad or does it actually like make
distinctively poor choices like is it
bad if i'm being stale or I'm not saying
but I'm not seeing bad for quality I'm
saying bad for things don't turn out
well oh no oh no oh goodness yeah so um
anyway
this is this is one of the times when
the what was I gonna say superpowers I
got that bob guy okay so Bob Shipman
he's it he's in online critic who he
basically came up for with this
breakdown this dissection of sucker
punch oh I'm always interested me
somebody has a breakdown a sucker punch
because you know either like pretty much
the same argument you've heard about you
like how problematic that movie is or
it's gonna be like some weirdly
impassioned like this is strong feminine
materials it basically is it's basically
the latter ero yeah he broke down this
this two-part video essay where you saw
belly look at Sucker Punch and this is
how it works out and this is the power
dynamic at play and basically broke out
how sucker punches kind of like this
multi-layered view of feminism in pop
culture and you know in how it's turned
back into a vector to cater to the male
gaze and how it needs to be kind of
superseded and and redone with a new
version of pop culture you know in yo
pop culture relevant feminism so that's
what that was in the broad strokes how
and but you know he says the movie
didn't exactly stick the landing on it
so Rob Chapman has this whole break
jumper house out the sucker punch and
its vectors of feminism work I'm pretty
sure you could go through ex machina
with a fine-tooth comb and point out how
Nathan and Caleb are both in and of
themselves like you know Caleb is the
the unknowingly misogynist nice guy in
nathan is the doesn't care about being a
misogynist or not frat bro hmm and at
the core of it is Ava who stands for you
know a feminine consciousness that is
seeking to attain her agency above all
else yeah you can break down you break
down X Macklin not just being about not
just being about AI not just being about
technology but all is not even just
thinking about the human condition but
being very specifically about gender
politics ya know that there's then I
think there's definitely I pick that up
you know sort of coming out of it
yeah there's that moment like at the
various you do have like what I feel
like any time you dry triangle that way
like you whether you meant to or not
there's always something about that but
can you make it play that bad comparison
but compared the like a love triangle of
the twilight movies like I don't think
the Twilight movies have anything
intelligent to say about feminism no not
at all but I'm saying like you've opened
up that argument I feel like whenever
you have two men and a woman in a sort
of confined space or or confined
dynamics yeah I feel you open yourself
up to the gender politics discussion
either way yeah but I mean I think like
this one does it intentionally yeah this
is like the gender politics are like the
movie is saying something wittingly
rather than the movie is say the movie
is delivering a message unwittingly yeah
well these are two guys who have their
hooks in her for two very different
reasons and ultimately she just wants to
be her own thing she wants and I mean
she does whatever she has to you know to
kind of be subject to her own will and
desire and I just got say one and you
can kind of under there's almost like
kind of like an interesting communion
between Ava and kyoko the mute yeah you
don't know what she is for the longest
time of the movie yeah um so there's
this interesting communion between Ava
and Kyoko in in ex machina that I think
if you're worth going very shallow very
surface level you can see it as almost
like you know you know like a
homoeroticism between the two of them
well but I think it's almost more like
it it's almost more like two animals
sniffing each other out and we just
don't know what informations are picking
up from each other because their
intelligence is not like our own yeah
yeah yeah that that moment they have in
the hallway yeah yeah where they first
kind of yet run into each other for the
first time and I do I mean I think
that's all there because I think there
is like a brief second we're not like
there's ever like a serious romantic
connection consider but there is a
moment where it's like it almost looks
sensual yeah it's like you're sort of
crunching numbers of like is this you
know are we I feel like that's very
subtly in that moment is there is a
slight sensuality to the way that they
sort of sway in and out of each other
for a second
it from along with those other things if
you're gonna read it that way then it
could be like that would throw another
wrench into the into the feminist
reading of the movie yeah cuz I mean
it's not it doesn't go in one direction
or the other that way you know they they
sort of pass and the bigger action that
scene takes hold but which by the way
was [ __ ] awesome which is fun great
and I mean I think like I was gonna say
like there's no way I mean first of all
I don't buy that anyone's kitchen eyes
aren't that [ __ ] sharp oh well yeah
cuz that like bone had to don't be gone
through in those in those relics man
yeah I drop but no like I'm that whole
that whole scenario it's like you know
you're kind of aware there are two other
people so when you adding another person
is like a very large percentage jump of
the people in your life space um so you
know for them to run into each other the
first time it she's the first person she
sees who looks like her yeah not a man
you know it's like I do blue well
there's not a man to who's not a human
yeah it's like there is a certain yet I
think there's just a very sort of
genuine little element of central it
comes out through that and it's just
sorta nother facet of that little
diamond um also just superficial thing
like a slow stab is really I don't know
there's something that makes you that
almost makes it that much more impactful
ugly way they're stabbing him in that
scene is just so kind of slow and it's
like no it's like it almost feels more
impassioned because it's slow yeah it's
like if you're really the knife is
really sliding and yeah it's like in and
then if you read the read that is like a
like a phallic image then that throws
yeah it's like this this it's almost
like this Hydra of a feminist reading of
ex machina is growing more heads yeah I
more you look into this like this this
penetrative action well and it's also
like such a machos like it's it looks
like a little katana doesn't it doesn't
have I get rings all over it yeah I
can't remember the night but I know it
was like one that's like very like full
tang the blade in the end
handle are one solid bit of metal
layering was like high-tech but kitchen
knives that you would get like from a
bong and olive sonore Hammacher
Schlemmer catalog yeah everything else
in Nathan's [ __ ] ass so that's the
thing like I don't know if it's like an
intentional reading you can take but it
is there like you know is good they are
thrusting this phallic thing into him
and it's you know his sword but she's
mel has backfired sodium like you just
got [ __ ] boy yeah it's like perhaps if
you had been a little more you know like
all ashen entities always things all the
deeds is is from Kyoko to recite the
exact dialogue from that kill bill bit
it's like would you like to penetrate me
Oh who's a guy vidit rated you yeah guys
who's getting the dick now if you had
been a little less of a dude about this
maybe maybe we couldn't work something
oh you could've worked this but nah not
be out of your dick you had to be a dick
and now you're getting the shaft is I
but who wouldn't know and i gotta say
like i don't think i've seen a death
scene since like Gus on Breaking Bad
that was as I mean as cool and as still
character revealing oh yeah as as Nathan
cuz Nathan's like walking out going like
hey this is great reaction because it is
like with this are you still you still
have not you still have not like gotten
your [ __ ] humility socked in to you
yeah when there's also like just the way
I just love the pitch of that moment
because like it's he says that in the
way someone does when like something's
really shitty happens at work where yeah
this is a fire I'm gonna definitely this
is gonna [ __ ] up my debts like he stood
it's not like he's still to the very end
feels untouchable well yeah because to
him it's like you know he's been
tinkering around like you know it's an
erector set for him so it's like do you
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] this up and now this
is a lot of work and headaches for me
you know you've tampered with incredibly
fragile and expensive machinery like
that's the level that that that kind of
comes out to me on yeah it's not it's
like is that that it's just like [ __ ]
you like you really it's like at that
point works just like that
narcissism comes out like he's still to
the end he does not understand he thinks
he's been in convenience not that he
exactly punished for for [ __ ] up yeah
it's like the reality this guy lives in
like this is just like a really shitty
day at the office with a new guy [ __ ]
up supreme yes like no this is your this
is your comeuppance man yeah this is
this is exactly it's like this is your
this is your hubris yeah this is
everything you have built yeah crashing
down for yours this you're lying in the
bed yo ass made yeah you actually you
made this bed now you're not your
cleaning lady this isn't a shitty day at
work this is the day you're gonna pay
the pipe it it's like you ever watch
home movies I hadn't that not like
religiously but I had since okay there's
that one episode in home movies where
they find out every movie ends with ends
with two characters telling a third it's
time to pay the price no just like this
is really bizarre mobile works like
every other go to all the booze just
like to the whole Annika's same wine
it's time to pay the price yeah oh so ya
know and then you end up with like macho
guys not the guy neither is nice guy the
guy yeah the only guy is the helicopter
pilot that's the guy that's the guy you
want to be an x rocker that the guy who
buys a helicopter you just drop you just
drop the do dogs like I'm not deal with
you guys you split you pick up the girl
at the end yeah exactly I just like
where are you going to oh yeah is like
you don't know enough to be invested so
you're safe here's my question what the
folks at the helicopter there had to
have been a scene considered if not
written in any film with the helicopter
pilot is like who are you yeah exactly
is like at first I was like so he's just
gonna take her yeah but I kind of feel
like that would bust of the flow to have
to deal with like who are you she
brought she probably killed him flew the
helicopter the rest of the way yourself
maybe you don't maybe not maybe she just
say like oh yeah no I'm working with
Nathan he told me she probably could
have nicked whatever security groom she
needed to prove it's like if she needed
something from inside she probably knew
what that was no what
what she liked or maybe it was like a
totally different pilots on the on the
return trip yeah what she goes to the
like would it have been okay if she had
gotten to the helicopter pilot and she
like I'm caught talked to the helicopter
pilot by name and he talked to her by
name and it's like they knew each other
and been working together the whole time
like what caleb thought he was the hero
of confidence in reality was that the
old helicopter pilot dude yeah I but how
would that have happened though like she
doesn't have the internet yeah she
doesn't have a phone unless she just
caught she got about before head yeah my
dish just like hey is this a Jerry this
is jay who can you fly to ya sultan is
actually i wrote an alternator she
actually skins caleb alive and wears his
skin what if the helicopter pilot was
another AI and that was what a horrible
life because like either that AI just
aspires to nothing or like is really
kind of slavish because this is like
Honor Flight helicopter from Norway to
America times like who's gonna transfer
people to better places than this
helicopter like I don't know it was like
a very simple first first edition is my
personal pilot this is the only thing he
knows that do ya I built his brain off a
flight simulator it's all it days is not
based on the blue books or attention or
the internet he's big he's based off of
the most recent edition of microsoft
flight sim yeah exactly nobody seemed
like a reasonable place to start he's
been to have motor skills right he's
based off of euro truck simulator 2014
that I just upgraded a whole bunch I
based this al Frogger I best this AI off
my watch this a is my microwave this is
my bike away oh I just that's what I
want out like I feel like if they ever
made a relay I it like it would start
kind of like that where it's like we
took all the guts like maybe it is super
smart and super lifelike and it's
intellect but I feel like the first day
eyes would still have to put all the
guts into like a laundry machine wheels
like here's this is just stuff that can
support
hold like some kind of power source and
all the texts that needs to make this
work you ever see silent running no okay
it was directed by douglas trumbull who
did all this or he was like the main
special effects guy on two-thousand 10
then so silent running was with Bruce
Dern um and it was like oh and music by
Joan Baez and it was like one of the
another one of that crop the last crop
the last major crop ahead of like ideas
driven sci-fi and it was it was you know
this heavy environmental message and all
the robots the assistant robots they
look like that they were like these big
like drone things that walked on legs
and have these big bulky bodies and
little like little grabber arm shouting
and I don't think they ever spoke they
just did what they were told they kind
of seem to have personalities so yeah
man nice to return ahead yeah i wanna i
want i want this to continue i was
garland to make it make do again well
he's working on what you work on that
barrel is called um but he's working out
another like writing directing a piece
it's um it's the next I heard movie ex
machina too it's not gonna to no no no
more die hard movies no idea he's worked
on that day he got sucked up by the
franchise monster oh well but you know
he did do he did do dredd 3d and I've
heard good things about right through
like that was one roof everyone saw the
trail was like dis and then I saw there
like hat isn't ya friggin though did
your okay things about the 3d yeah i
mean i don't i don't think it's terribly
hard to like make a remake of dread that
isn't that you know outshines the
stallone version of a parson yeah he's
adapting a book called annihilation
really get the book i was an aisle a
shin about um is it matter I signs up
for a dangerous secret expedition where
the laws of nature don't apply of course
does that mean and just have to see the
movie fine like the laws of nature don't
apply like gravity flings you away from
other things
back yes left it was just a guy bouncing
in between planets it's terrible why did
we ever think to come here and that he's
writing a couple of things Oh apparently
they're like halo they're doing the hat
off I don't know well see again like I
trust his track record enough to this
point that if he's doing halo a it'll
probably at least be as interesting as
that movie could have possibly been
under the circumstances and be he like
it seems like he would do that so that
you may be has the means to do another
one of these yeah buts like you know
Tony Joe of every frame of painting he
was on Twitter about the news that neill
blomkamp got you know signed on to do an
alien sequel he was just like you know a
few years back everyone wanted more like
original complex intelligence sci-fi and
now you're happy to see me Oh bloom calm
you know doux-doux an alien sequel I
mean not realistically speaking getting
sucked into franchise world doesn't do
anything except trapped in franchise
world also I think the level that I
think the thing that holds that argument
for a lot of the people who are saying
that is the fact that aliens of
franchise where everyone feels like it
went wrong at a certain point so we'll
forgive the lack of originality and
doing another franchise piece if it'll
fix the timeline and that's what we were
like so excited about their low it's
gonna be like right after aliens which
was less when everyone can agree on and
it's gonna perhaps you know but I mean
also look at like Kenneth Branagh like a
bronc does a Thor movie and then what
was he doing chores he does Cinderella
so it's like he's I mean granted i still
buy that Kenneth Branagh is putting in
good work but it's like I would be cool
to see kenneth branagh do something new
and not like just keep on doing rehash
Disney stuff it's all I wish Tim Burton
would do yeah but I mean wow big guys
apparently was was well received yeah
yeah yeah and I mean that I still got
see that I mean that's still not
entirely original property cause it is
biopic he owes you know biography but
you know yeah
and I it's interesting because like I'm
not against that sort of thing like i
like when you know proven interesting
film makers will go out and do a
franchise piece just because you know
it's like it does usually seem to
elevate it some end and i'm not against
those kinds of movies i'm just against
the fact that they're swallowing
everything up yeah you know so it's like
if you have Kenneth Brown Thor movie
like that made a Thor movie more
interesting than a standard comic book
movie for me so that's like cool but I'm
sort of with you there's like I wish
there was more of like instead of going
and doing another big property it's like
me I'm gonna take some time off and do
something interesting like you know I
want to see kenneth branagh do um you
know what's his name of time'n sore you
know go back to doing is you know go do
some like problem plays cuz you know he
loves his Shakespeare ya know I I wish
that you know that would be more of a
thing yeah it's like I don't know cuz I
again it's I wish that it can't be a
rule it's like it all depends on what
you want to do but I feel like for those
kinds of filmmakers would be like do a
big one then do a little and then do
another big one and then do another
little one if you have to so like every
other year you're sort of working more
of your farm side and more of your ideas
right yeah but um I mean what's in
wasn't Duncan Jones's pipeline or craft
what Warcraft oh that's right it and I
don't get why why Warcraft this like
moon how do you go from moon and source
code to warcraft well I fill out yeah
that is a little like just just
logically speaking it as a little weird
I feel like somebody looked at Duncan
Jones it's like yeah it looks like Peter
Jackson enough books elves bum on this
uh elfin orc movie well that's a weird
choice to cos it like that doesn't work
I doesn't have like a discernible story
where it just has elements rights as a
world and you know casts of character is
you don't like I don't know I'm like I
know the original Warcraft games like
warcraft warcraft warcraft 3 I mean
there I don't know if they were like
Diablo where they were just have free
form that's the work I've always looks
like now that was like yeah
we'll grate a character and you sort of
live in this world and that's what crap
[ __ ] yeah that's world of warcraft the
MMO but i don't know if like the
original games had like a mythology
already okay like or not a mythology but
like a plot yet into them like ghetto
and narrative like there's you know the
fallout universe in the fallout world
but like each individual fallout games
about specific character doing a
specific storyline with a specific plot
and specific you know signposts along
the way so i know which it's more like
be good I mean I guess I wouldn't be
surprised in that case I guess which is
World of Warcraft is like the thing that
I'm most mm-hmm I didn't for somebody I
should have realized there would just be
world or just Warcraft games you know
like I'm curious as to how you take
something like halo and make it into a
make it into a movie cuz sleep doesn't
it already have a narrative that spans
like a 12 ish our like campaign yeah
well that seems to be a fundable as I
gundrum almost like a side story in the
Halo universe that's I think what it
ultimately end up being just that seems
to be one of the problematic things that
stands in the way of getting a good
video game movie made is like because it
Lisa it maybe not a good but like one
that satisfies its fans cuz like you
look at resident evil the movie and
resident evil movie doesn't have a ton
to do with the game like it kind of does
like it kind of takes place in a mansion
with a lab under it and there are
zombies but you know it's like the
characters the story line itself
different you know hmm and so I think
there's this weird doing hang-up about
do we want to tell the story of the game
but they've played that so do we do a
different story in that universe and I
feel like Silent Hill kind of does that
right because it takes you know Silent
Hill is a character yeah and it throws
new ideas person into it yet whereas
this halo it's like you know Master
Chief is sort of your established
protagonist when you're the last of his
kind it's like the whole the whole halo
universe is built around captain king or
whatever his name's yeah and you know
you have at least in the first game of
the first couple games you know the
isn't are they a day at war with the
Covenant or whatever yeah and so like it
seems like it seems like what you'd make
your first halo movie about but I don't
know because we're also cresting into a
time it's like we don't get as many
video game movies generally we're at a
time where people really care if stuff
resembles its subject its source
material no it's like in the past I feel
like you know comic book movies video
game movies they've come out and it
didn't really matter if they had stuff
to do because they're more sporadic but
now especially we have so many comic
book movies and they all you know
there's a bigger level of people who are
well-versed in those comics and what
they're about and the tones and the
characters and stuff like that I feel
like now you kind of have to make a
video game that draws from the game and
and incorporate that stuff heavily
because you can't do another final
fantasy thing where it's like this
doesn't have anything to do with final
fantasy but it's kind of got this weird
abstract element and people know the
name I see we're gonna call it final
fantasy like I don't think you can do
that anymore yeah because geek culture
and like the voices are so loud but at
the same time it's like the I mean in
this could be like an exception that in
a way proves the rule like the Marvel
Universe the comics have adapted to kind
of resemble the movies more yeah
supposedly so I mean I don't know but
Marvel's building their giant war
machine of properties so I don't know
what that and also I mean you to a
degree a lot of these comics have been
around for so long that again I don't
know where any of these these phases or
ships or anything are in the Marvel
comic book universe but yeah it's like
DC just did their new 52 a few years ago
it's like maybe was getting time to sort
of shake up the franchise's and that's
anyway and that's the difference between
I mean as far as I'm aware that's a big
difference between DC and Marvel and how
they handle things works like in the DC
Universe they keep on having to like
they have to go to alternate worlds and
alternate
and have a new justification for how
things happened and you know they had
the crisis side where were all the
alternate universes of different
superheroes were somehow melded or
aligned some out whereas in the Marvel
world it's like everything happened just
a few years ago every major event
happened a few years ago no matter if
you're picking up a comic I was made in
the 60s or made you know today or made
in the 80's every major event that
shakes the lives of these characters
after a few years ago yeah why she hey I
don't necessarily think when 2 Peter
Parker graduate a few years ago this is
perpetually a few years out of school
exactly yeah well I mean that's it
that's that's one of those weird
artistic dynamic things cuz like
everything is recent in a lot of
cartoons too it's like you know nothing
was ever that long ago it's you know
this characters dog cage yeah it's just
always them on a different day an exact
same clothes yes this sort of like the
time of life becomes nebula in favor of
new adventures because like nobody has
time to [ __ ] redesign a character
with a different outfit every year so
what that but you know like severed
Stephen silver impossible as a week hmm
like I don't know it's in the it depends
on like if you're veering more towards
like the universe and the story and all
that stuff versus like making your
characters get old overt I'd like to
break it down into its I comic book
characters run hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of issues with it so it's like
you can you can show characters age and
change and shift over 10 seasons of a TV
show because you only have 24 episodes
in each one and you can sort of
purchasing them off but it literally
comic books totally would be aging so
much yeah and comic book starts string
from one to the next for so long that I
just think it'd be very [ __ ] up if
like they just had the characters age
more or less in real time and tater
partners now in his 60s London Peter
partner died a few times yeah but I
think he also got brought back to life
or something already died only an
alternate universe or something
something happens
well that's the other thing to you as
like comic books now it's like there's
the ultimate spider-man the amazing
spider-man and spider-man there was like
Batman and detective comics and like
this and double Batman is they're always
like different different timelines and
or different universes and then
different you know cuz if you like this
and when they do like the elf's world
stuff that's more like alternative like
it's more yeah it's like what if this
happened yeah what if this happened in
one concept wait huh just like what if
you know what if Peter Parker guys dick
caught in an elevator well please write
that it should i just want to know now
they're just be one panel just like a
close-up of his face screaming hey you
turn the pages just save as screaming on
every page that break for an ad and then
i'm screaming on the last few pages and
then there's a two-page spread of him
screaming like a really touching okay
yeah i mean i get comic book vs movie
all this stuff is kind of weird to me
especially when it's like the movies are
influencing the comics now more to and
on the one hand it's like I don't mind
that because on it on the more innocent
side of the spectrum it is like yeah I
can understand wanting like if you're a
kid you're reading a comic book and it
also looks exactly that way in the movie
it sort of closes the gap between you
know being able to really like imagine
in the real world it's like if you close
the out like the valley between those
two like I can see how there's like
Wonder and magic to be created from that
but then on the other side of it is also
kind of like everything's homogenized
really easy to market and so it's kind
of evil to like I'm sorry that I'm sorry
that this is like going totally of
course but I just thought of something
yeah okay you know how there's the bit
in ex machina where you know they have
that whole Marvel DC today no like Caleb
says the plan the escape plan and then
you know and then Nathan's like well how
was that siski plane gonna work and you
know he does is always going to do this
and that and
and you know Nathan was they go yeah
that was interesting but then something
and then kill was like yeah that's why I
did last night yeah I was for whatever
reason it's like that remind me so that
first of all it was brilliant cuz like
oh my god yeah that cuz when you did
that you did that cuz I saw you do that
that means you did that but it's like do
you think it was a purposeful at all
there was any purposeful connection to
the I did at 35 minutes ago from
watchmen I cuz we're ripping on comics
again oh [ __ ] okay it's been one sec
watch me just refresh me on that on all
the context of that scene again he did
35 minutes ago you have a witch it um so
which is the night owl and Rorschach go
into adrian veidt's layer yes sent to
all on the watchtower by jimi hendrix
yeah nor the hendrix cover of the Bob
Dylan song head and you know they go in
and they say Adrienne but it's like what
was your plan how is it going to work
and in Adrian says this was my plan this
is how it was gonna work and it was all
like very comic book monologue E and you
know it's like well we're here to stop
you and he's like what the [ __ ] you
think I am like a cartoon villain I did
it but I triggered this whole thing 35
minutes ago yeah I'm only telling you
because it's already happy you can't do
anything about it now like I get to have
my moment of hubris but I was also smart
about this year's like I was only going
to tell I'm only telling you this
because it's like there's nothing you
can do it's already happened yeah I mean
well in an ex machina is like it it
makes sense yeah to the characters
whereas in watch landed you had like a
whole [ __ ] it's also brilliance like I
want to I want to rewatch my ex machina
and see it's like cuz with the
chronology Vic's mama de things like it
feels like when caleb is telling telling
Ava the plan you think he's telling Ava
the plan you know because he just did an
element of it and so that's what gave
him the idea for the plan because he saw
a part of it worked out
it's that thinking he already executed
the entirety of the plan yeah so it's
like you know it's like the moment where
you see him the moment you think a
moment is him discovering the plan when
it's really him executing the plan and I
want to rewatch ex machina and see if
that moment looks like he is executing
or discovery okay like it doesn't listen
to on see ya in the nuances in the
performs and um dumpin all Gleason
domino domino run down Rob this is your
father would pick up the phone hello no
hello don't know don't know don't know
pick up the phone it's your father
brendan brendan gleeson like I just like
the notion that that's how he introduces
himself to his children does if they
have forgotten yeah this is your father
brendan brendan brendan gleeson um from
in Bruce then like dad have done another
movie I'm hager insane oh it's mad eye
moody bro get it right Gibbs Hagrid
Robbie Coltrane oh [ __ ] that's right
yeah may he rest in peace he died yeah
what do you died when a grande ecole
trend i sin thieves indeed I was last
year [ __ ] do ya know he's been Bob
Hoskins you you know wait Bob houses was
a Harry Potter movies no but didn't they
they die they die close to each other am
I wrong who was emo no you know why what
robbie coltrane is not dead richard
griffiths is dead richard griffiths play
uncle Bern uh yes oh and he was in
history boys yeah dad's I'm sorry yeah
that's right Marie on the second um who
was in from hell was that robbie
coltrane again yes okay that was a
robbie coltrane it was not brendan
gleeson no I can see how you get them
they're both like big they're like both
big UK guys I have like they speak in
kind of a hurry tone yeah yeah yeah they
have a they have time a similar look but
now there's yeah they are very different
Wow robbie coltrane is not his real name
what's his real name Anthony Robert
McMillan what
the culturing come from I think no idea
wasn't way into jazz he's just so if
just sitting around home with his with
his buddies one night listen to a jazz
records like man at Coltrane yeah hey
I've been looking for a stage name I
won't cooperate my love of jazz just
humming a Love Supreme to himself yeah
was a love supreme court right check
email ask the info Tron ask Siri ask Ava
was it love love supreme I love supreme
3d they love supreme no tomato I love
supreme John Coltrane okay I knew it
also the also the theme song to KCRW's
which way la oh [ __ ] a love supreme of
the Supreme igloo mm-hmm mm-hmm I you
know say what you will about that movie
wolf wall straight that scene is it's
very memorable scene the humming it is a
great scene like the the scene with
Makana how I yeah McConaghy no good so
weird speaking of like weird musical
songs how about deacons [ __ ] tearing
up the dance floor oh oh that that was
the scene where like the fact that he
was gonna tear up the dance floor I
didn't believe him but then you didn't
tore up the dance and the fact that like
he knows the exact same choreography as
Kyoko's like you it's like it feels very
like this is [ __ ] this is Charles
Foster Kane and he has been locked up
inside of Xanadu too damn long is that
he has lost the plot you have it's
almost like and that's something very
injured thats like I I pit Nathan as far
as like crazy movie villains I put them
right up there with like like um God
what's his name from blue velvet oh I
love ya
david lynch's Twitter's there oh yeah
David Lynch is just different one
wonderful Twitter Minh except for except
for when he like gave a shout out to dr.
oz I'm like yeah mmm David if you
something that needs on only their
doctor husby check this [ __ ] out with
some ganyan many uh frankbooth
frankbooth yeah Frank from blue velvet
as far as like movie villains that had
that domineering presence but then they
become ridiculous but they become more
terrifying when they become more
ridiculous well because it's ridiculous
but but only in the sense that you just
don't expect that from that guy like you
know it's it's just such a weird
character moment no it's like I know
we've been dealing with robots and [ __ ]
all day Anna really into fitness but I'm
just down for some disco Yeah right yeah
and that's another thing it's like in
the the red lights come on again in the
dance room and just like so brilliantly
unnerving it's like it's like this guy
it's like that scene better than
anything else is a great character model
for Nathan because it shows like this is
what this guy as much as he's into a
pioneering AI at the core of him what he
really wants to do is create this
terrifying sexual dream world yeah yeah
yeah it really it's like you you are in
this you this is him I am King look at
my sexy robot woman dancing with me that
helps me work out that helps you to work
out and we'd be [ __ ] later yeah it's
like II I've got it all I designed the
perfect yeah girlfriend and perfect you
know sex bungalow yeah this [ __ ]
compound in a glacier [ __ ] colony
welcome to my [ __ ] house welcome to [ __ ]
house welcome to [ __ ] house Christ uh um
legend [ __ ] out rowdy roddy mcdowall
so yeah it's not gonna ex machina man
and the clothing was about the use of
the title it's like it you know it's
like we're used to deus ex machina
getting turned into a tile because just
like talking about like you know
transcendence or you know the
technological singularity and you know
like the daves x games they use it it's
like deus ex machina it's a perfect
double feature play all of days x and
then watch next fun look it's not much a
double feature this is double experience
yeah looks like double screen like deus
ex it's about about human McCann like
human machine singularity it's about the
you know human transcendence with the
with the use of implants and technology
and ex machina is it with Dave's exits
like it strips deus ex machina to God
from you know it's like you know about
transcending entertaining some kind of
godhood in this transcendent way yeah um
whereas ex machina it's like it takes
away the gods you just have from the
machine so it's like X market is asking
it turns it all this into a question
it's like what's coming from the machine
yeah it's like what in that's the
central like that's such the pillar of
the of the moves mysteries like what's
what is what is coming out of them this
machine was coming out of Ava what's
coming out of this AI capacity in
general yeah exactly so yeah in every
way it's like what is it is it authentic
you know is it is it honest yeah is it a
ploy to put in yeah 3.5 out of 5 this is
the official rating 3 out of 5 is the
official rating in the Rolling Stone
really yeah welcome Peter Travers most
things are three out of five on Rolling
Stone with his music I'm thuggin Peter
Travers like Stone also has this thing
we're like they'll give a good for every
good star rating ever like four out of
five the written reviews sounds really
negative and then forever like two out
of five it's always like you know
it's okay like what is to read so much
more positive than for it's like such a
consistent right it's like somebody else
comes up with a rating based on the
review yeah yeah weird so yeah it sounds
positively what about writing and you do
the review this you crunch the numbers
yeah it's a weird yeah so ex machina
xpac not good movie fantastic so I
favorite this year yeah I really
happened there's some some you know
explosions light ideas heavy sigh fly
coming around cousin call single
explosion it was not a single one um
except for when except for when Nathan
tore up the dance floor yeah that was an
explosion in the pants yeah well great
yeah good but now like you know ideas
heavy interesting thoughtful sci-fi cuz
like we had predestination back in
January and that was a movie that just
kind of got shoved there because I don't
think they knew what to do with it and
it's like I was wish ex machina if we
could have just sweat I feel like
someone is sitting there in an office me
if we had just put hot pursuit out in
January and put her destination a week
or two after ex machina this would have
been great yeah that's what it feels
like it's like and I haven't seen
printed destination buddy I heard really
good things about it was that that was
another one those movies where like it
got a couple minutes in and the first
major scene between the two main
characters it got to be like 45 minutes
not like oh they're still talking yeah
oh it's this kind of like you're really
excited for booze I got people talk
you're gonna talk for like more than
enough time it takes to get the
exposition out oh yeah that's another
thing about ex machina does really good
it takes the time to actually like it
it's very realistic like these people
are talking about like these old old AI
thought experiments and they're talking
them in full but so colloquially and
with the you know with the with the
language that you use when both of you
know it well yeah exactly it's like that
then the movie the writing finds a way
to strike a really nice balance between
like it's smart without being
condescending yeah and it's also not to
like big blocky dumb ideas like to
kind of try and paraphrase smart ideas
it's like exactly it's like it uses its
brains in a way that somebody who knows
and who's actually done the reading it
would and it's like there's there's even
tensions like Caleb and Nathan will be
talking about you know they'll be
talking about like AI thought
experiments and and different aspects of
it and how work and it's like they're
still character tension there there's
still you know very to clear
perspectives that are kind of at odds in
discussing the discussing the topic well
and in that Iran to like it's a further
clash because it's like you know it's
that's a place where the amount of
knowledge and the amount of you know
intimate experience you have with like
the numbers and art stuff is it kind of
like a political tool you know it's like
smarts are definitely being judged upon
in that room yeah you know so I was like
you can understand like Caleb using the
more more intricate language because he
wants to make it yeah it's like I want
to prove do you improve the how that I
know this really well yeah and then
Nathan wait Caleb saying is neither yeah
and the Nathan's like he's very
nonchalant about it because you know
he's mr. macho man like it ain't nothing
little thing you know like [ __ ]
Turing test bro I don't it you know this
gone dude it's my husband yeah robot
yeah come over my house [ __ ] would I got
this robot is right by my house is
robust but my house it's like this is a
cool name but it's got guys oh yeah like
it's just nice to have it cuz like
predestination is the same way where
it's like I I had a vague inkling for
the idea and so I was like I was prepped
for something more like high paced
action and then I saw it I was like whoa
there's so much here that I was not
expecting and even thinking would happen
like you know just like places that Sora
and ideas it touches upon where I was
like wow this is nothing like what I
expected you to mrs. receive every
destinations I mean it can't it wasn't a
genuine release mmm Jenny where is like
Jane or 18th ya january is dumping
ground well january demographic but what
I love about January is that there's
always like one or
two movies that they just didn't quite
know what to do with that are always
kind of interesting yeah cuz it is still
like it I mean not to say like the
production value is pretty good and like
you know it is it's sort of some of it
as period and some of its futuristic and
some of its future period um so like
it's definitely not like a cheap movie
but it's a low-budget movie kinda like
this is um so they're a little like
low-budget phrase around the edges and
stuff um so it's not necessarily like so
sleek as to be like a big summer movie
yeah but it's also just really well done
really interesting and it's just kind of
weird i guess like for words like ex
machina is it's coming out beginning of
summer is going against me the avengers
yeah but it's getting bigger releases
this time it's like it came out like i
need the New York LA thing like you know
a month ago and then a week or two ago
it came out wide and now it's going
lighter and yeah it's like every week
there it's me more theaters yet which is
that semi has gotta be awesome for them
yeah you know cuz this is this is the
risky movie right now where it's like
you know we're gonna do sci-fi but
stuffs not gonna explode it's about
these two dudes discussing ideas and
then testing out and talk it's all
talking yeah like some people talking
like they do a lot with people talking
ya know and it still manages to be super
thrilling and that's I think this is a
great like I really haven't see do well
cuz that proves it's like no no you can
have just ideas and just people talking
it can still be tense and and you can
still be you know really immersed in it
and get masses and seeds yeah exactly
you know it's still thrilling as far as
you know intelligent sci-fi booze is
probably my favorite movie since her and
then now that's a double feature that
would be an interesting if I would say
hurts watch her second cuz it ends on a
lighter note hey i jizz and warmer it
it's still kind of sad but still also
it's bittersweet yeah it's bittersweet
but it does have a nice warm glow around
it yeah you know whereas this one has
sort of a cold glow around it you know
it's still sunlight but it's like um
like her at the last taste hers in your
mouth is like semi-sweet chocolate
whereas the end of X muffin is like
sucking on an ice cube yeah but it's
like it's cold but not because they did
something wrong it's cool because they
meant to be yeah yeah it's it's cold
yeah I would say it's like cool yeah
it's not like cold cold there's a little
bit of warmth in there but it is it's
the colder side of bittersweet it's like
ex machina is the more bitter side of
bittersweet and her is the sweeter side
is their sweet yeah that would be a cool
double piece for the Beatrice so that's
a double feature for you guys your
homework tonight play JS x then have a
double feature of ex machina and her and
then earth then even kiss your mama tell
toted you love and throw your computer
in a river kill your computer with an ax
yeah right after you shaving it Hey look
at all these callbacks yeah call it acts
you were show yes oh I think about wraps
it up I think that about wraps it up
what we discussed it written yeah we
talked about the ex machina we talked
about dais yo dude Amadeus on the day
rockin um I got it God big suit fix fix
fix it that zoo suit shower head zoot
suit kid we talked about yeah well if
the leasing return bob index was like a
child that thought everything that was
big was cool ya know ya is like it's
that simple I can't remember how the
jokes start but yeah the way you said
it's like it sounded like when you're
hit everything new yeah it's like
everything that's big just like big or
or you know loud just equates to
coolness when you're little cuz it's you
know it's simple yeah just like I was
like trying really hard to be you know a
badass in the Zoot Suit community with
it's like oh I'm sure Joe really big
shoot there's a big suit this is my big
band and we're gonna play play play big
song big song it's big it's good song
cuz it's big song it's a bit fun huh
this is time he plays a big big trombone
pick trombone so many sounds
no big trumpet and this is blind willie
and he's playing drums big dog big drum
syndrome this is drunk Oh boom boom boom
boom boom boom big drop some big drums I
got big hat and big big big better and
big hat and and this guy over here
little piano that's a big little piece
yeah big dick pics out example pick some
lumpia big big big p.m. ok I 1 and 2 and
on 1 2 3 big this search crooning max as
a that is a joke that gets a lot of
mileage with me so and if when not it
saids it seems to be like a stock joke
for any like folk music comedy duo uh
where it's like you start a song with
what about you one two three and then
you go into this like really really oh
yeah downtempo really pretty slow yeah
yeah this is a joke it gets really fun
of me that and like taking trivial
things way to serve it like this my
lonely island songs were for me because
it's a good amount of them are about
taking something vaguely mundane and
getting way too excited abuse or when
them I like God when andy samberg writes
lyrics like his the song day rovers the
hollywood [ __ ] game on comedy bang bang
o course is like being dorky and Goofy
like being excited about things but like
just can't but everything is just wrong
like check out the facts is the
hollywood fact or hollywood facts are
going downtown go to angle one now it's
just like a one point he can't make the
ride it is like i did take a step
outside the Chinese Theater it's totally
off all right ah I do appreciate
appreciated so yeah that or like taking
uh taking like colloquial ideas and
making them literal have another song uh
I think it's just called I run New York
but is from the actual perspective the
mayor of New York you should talk about
what a shitty job it is and how
difficult everything is it's like or
like I'm a boss it's like is this is
similar kind of song yeah we're just
talking about how difficult and trying
the job is and finally
how it falls off the rails and spirals
in the madness yeah exactly and like the
only reason he's doing is it something
ridiculous but yeah good stuff Mary oh
man so CX talk about ya see da da big
movie just take movie look big movie
it's a big ID